are you okay go I'm curious how you
interpreted the ending and what those
conversations were like well what did
you think I wouldn't know what you
thought I'm like a very much like
believed women so I was like she's not
crazy
thank you she knows yeah your gut is
always right yeah absolutely and I was
important to us to kind of try to map
out really carefully that there was a
small there's a small period when she
thinks am I crazy I could be wrong we
wanted with Adrienne we wanted that when
the audience finally get to spend time
with him that he be incredibly confusing
to an audience we wanted it we what I
think it's very indicative of what
people like this alike and specifically
in those kind of relationships where
it's all about manipulation it's all
about control they know how to act in
order to be to get someone back they
know how to manipulate the other person
and to be charming and and that's I
think ultimately was so terrifying about
Adrienne is the there is not a single
part of him that can be trusted and so
I'm glad that that that was the kind of
reaction that you had because that's
kind of audience was like we're getting
gas lit now like we're in this - he said
that wherever I went he would find me
walk right up to me and I wouldn't be
able to see him I mean I guess I like
the idea that some people take away
different things from it for me I wanted
it to be something cathartic like
something where the audience could walk
away feeling like there was some sense
of catharsis and victory but if you were
to say well I kind of see it like maybe
then I would be happy about that but
it's super smart you know a lot of that
it was Lee Lizzie and I discussed it a
great length you know there is a version
of it where I very easily could be like
and it would be I think that it would be
not only boring but it would leave her
in a really fascinating story and
you know and it is about gas lighting
and it is about all of these really
important topics and so we wanted to do
it as honestly as possible and this is
how people like that operate he has
figured out a way to be invisible you
know exactly what I'm talking about he's
not dead
and then we very carefully put things in
place so that you were with her so you
believe her through the story so that
you're on her side so you know that
she's right and it's everyone else that
thinks she's crazy which is dramatically
really powerful here's what I love about
movies is like ten people who have ten
different opinions yeah that
conversation by the concessions like you
know you get out it's the same thing I
do when I come out of a movie I've
gotten into full-blown arguments with
people because they don't think No
Country for Old Men is a good film and
I'm acting like it's a given like yes it
is you're wrong you are definitively
wrong and I'll get mad with people for
their taste and ease and we know it's
all subjective but you can't be helped
but be passionate about this stuff I
haven't seen the film so I don't know
how it's like pieced together but I hear
it's crazy and I'm glad that Cecilia was
able to prove her sanity and I feel like
proving your sanity is hard but it's
even harder as a woman to prove your
sanity and I know that scene that they
shot was incredible and it does trick
you into thinking like what's happening
is she crazy is he crazy what's going on
right but she's able to come out on top
and and really save her life and and get
her joy and her happiness back and
that's the most important thing you are
okay so it is it like a one-and-done
thing or do you think there's room for
her to maybe come back who knows I mean
I think with any of these things you
have to wait to see what the audience
responds to and if they if they want
more um you know there is an ending
obviously that allows for that but at
the same time I you can't think about
that we just want people to enjoy this
film do you think a sequel for this one
as possible I don't know it's up to the
world to decide that like those sort of
questions get answered by the movie
going public
you know as you know Hollywood economics
is oh it did well let's do it again
well I'm very exactly I never I mean I'm
so superstitious about the success of a
film I don't want to jinx it by talking
about a sequels I feel like there's
movie gods looking over us and I'll
anchor them if I start talking about a
sequel so after the movies come out and
a little bit of time has passed maybe
I'll think about that
[Music]